but we're all winners here I'm Chris
Hardwick
so 2016 has been described by
meteorologists as a class-five show so I
want to take a break from the bad news
of the world courtesy the adorable news
of the World Wide Web well let's do it
because honestly you guys we have been
we have been neck deep in crap news this
entire year between between terrorism
and Zika and the election virus and
losing people pop culture icons that we
love 2016 so 2016 has definitely been
the year of no chill so we decided that
we were gonna give you a mental break
from all that stuff tonight that is that
this entire show is just an escape pod
for you emotionally let's start with my
sweater
I feel better surrounded by fuzzy wuzzy
bears all right it covers up my boobies
I feel better I feel better when I get
stressed out I go what am I gonna do and
then I'll shows up and goes no problem
Chris
so tonight everything we're doing is
cuter than a bug's ear and a bug's ear
is pretty cute welcome to I Can
Has midnight
alright one of the biggest stories of
the election was WikiLeaks the hacking
organization led by Julian Assange aka
Men's Rights Sephiroth who is possibly
aided by Russia and whose revelations
may have swung the election but who
gives a anymores cat wears a tie that's
what I care about he's stuck in that
embassy all these years that's probably
his best friend and probable lover
we don't know could be who would you
rather human or a cat it's a tie I know
huh I kill me comedians Julian Assange
has to build a lot of government secrets
what's the secret he might learn from
his cat Randy I'm sorry forgot to
mention we change the buzzer nuts today
Randy Garfield doesn't hate mondays he
hates Mormons it was a typo okay points
points three dogs died in Benghazi all
right Lula a cat ladies aren't actually
lonely they are secretly super hot
intercourse machines no not a dog I'm
sorry yeah a puppy that is threatening
to kill bystanders with cuteness we have
to check in on this going live what
appears to be someone's bathroom floor
Jack take us there please
oh the humanity what a truly adorable
moment we will bring you live real-time
updates as they come in on tub watch 16
remember you heard it here first on
@midnight
the first and only network brave enough
to bring you tub watch please stay with
us and don't pause your DVRs
now back to our regularly scheduled
program next up some pigs one of the
stories captivating the nation tonight
two fun guinea pigs are sharing a
healthy snack we take you to the Twitter
video already in progress
comedians your question about this video
what's the name of this hardcore porno
Randy do me in a urine-soaked pile of
newspaper
block volume four points Flula
it's very strange two pigs one snack
rabies in the Tramp yes boy
next up all dogs go to college all dogs
go to college courtesy of the aw
subreddit here's a pup named Bubba who's
a certified cutie pie that's a good boy
oh by the way that degree took him 28
dog years again comedians what was this
collared coeds major Randy dingleberry
horticulture all right points Sara
psychology with with a focus on
emotionally supporting a fragile white
woman who cannot even alright boys Lulla
advanced resting bitchface
like very sweet you know what just for
fun I'm gonna give you guys all each 100
points good already
oh I'm sorry I'm just getting this
breaking news now back to a tough watch
2016 update updates now the total counts
is now 17 dead from cuteness let's check
in with the puppies progress and see how
he's doing with that bath live from the
scene
not sure what three that is it looks
like something to Muppet baby cops up
when he chokes on cotton candy but it is
an adorable comedians this puppy has
permed in dangerous I would like you to
give me an eyewitness description of the
perp so that people can be on the
lookout look oh it looks like a deer has
pooped on the cloud yes yeah boy yeah
he's like these are little poops oops
tiny deer poo poos oh that is adorable
aren't you guys feeling better already
about the world chicken with his
scoreboards with 600 adorable pink
points his new album animal bum is now
available on iTunes Flula Borg and with
600 star points her new digital series
woman online is coming soon - seriously
TV Sara Schaefer
and with 500 Sparkle points performing a
Doc's lab in San Francisco November 21st
Randi lit cave and now the world while
it burns it's time for tonight's hashtag
guys what's cuter than cats baby cats
that's what's cuter than ice from a
woman in the audience who had never seen
a cat and baby farm before they're
called kittens that's what we call them
ma'am
and since we're fully committed to
keeping this episode as cute as possible
tonight's hashtag is cat TV examples
might be the theme song is yum yum yum
no no no no 60 seconds for you on the
clock and begin
Randy licky Downton tabby yes points
Sara Schaefer sex in the kitty points
Loula desperate house cats yes boys Sara
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire
points Randy litter box on the Prairie
boys Sara eastbound and put down Yaga
she wrote boys already scared by the
Bell
all right boys Randy mouse instead of
house yeah yeah
bula two and a half men who are also
allergic to cats all right good very
good that is the end of the hashtag Wars
please send us your hashtag cat TV and
tag those @midnight to keep this
adorable train going we'll be right back
with more cat midnight last night's
hashtag war was sent to us by MTM 1977